Not everything in this world is exactly as
it seems.
In fact, there are many creatures in the wild
that go out of their way to be deceptive,
to disguise themselves as something entirely
different from their true nature.
Aggressive Mimicry refers to a phenomenon
in which predators or parasites take on the
appearance of something harmless or even appealing,
in order to lure in their intended prey or
host without detection.
They might resemble food, an inanimate part
of the environment, or even a potential mate.
Whatever they choose, they're secretly a wolf
in sheep's clothing.
In the deep dark waters of the ocean, the
Anglerfish dangles an alluring light from
its head, ushering in little fish that it
can trap in its mouth and devour whole.
The alligator snapping turtle wiggles its
long tongue like a worm, attractive hungry
fish looking for their next meal.
Instead, they become the meal for something
bigger and more clever than them.
False cleanerfish share the appearance of
another species, one that helps clean larger
fish in a symbiotic relationship.
When the imposters find a victim, they swim
close under the pretense of cleaning, only
to take a bite out of them and swim away.
Predators use similar illusions on land, too.
Antimimicking jumping spiders wave their false
antennae in the air in an imitation of an
ant's movements, isolating the insects from
their colony before dragging them back to
their lair to be devoured.
The mouthparts of the male spiders are shaped
like the head of an ant, but this imitation
head splits apart to reveal the spider's fangs,
and its true intentions.
The Photuris firefly lights up its body in
a mimicry of other firefly species' mating
signals, signaling male fireflies looking
for companionship.
When they respond to the call however, they
will not find a willing mate waiting, but
instead a femme fatale of a firefly that just
wants to eat.
The spider-tailed horned viper has a bulbous
tip on its tail, with false legs jutting out
on either side.
As the snake wiggles its tail, running it
across the ground while the rest of its body
lies in wait just out of sight, a hungry bird
spots it from above.
When the bird swoops down to seize the opportunity,
the snake reveals itself, snapping up the
unfortunate bird before it can escape.
Thankfully, humans are so much smarter and
more observant than fish, ants, and birds.
We're safe from this sort of trickery.
There aren't any animals out there who've
learned how to look like something familiar,
something everyday, just to put unsuspecting
people at ease and lure us into its waiting
jaws...right?
Wrong.
Only a couple of years ago, the SCP Foundation
discovered a being that has mastered aggressive
mimicry on a level previously unseen in the
natural world.
Unfortunately for us, its prey of choice happens
to be humans, and its hunting ground is the
very cities where we like to think we're safe
from something much bigger, meaner, and hungrier
than us.
A short video went viral on a popular social
media platform.
The specific platform has been redacted from
official files, but the details of it are
clear: A popular creator on the app, a young
woman known for her makeup tutorials and restaurant
recommendations around her native city of
Los Angeles.
She was live streaming and answering questions
while going about her day, when she stepped
onto a train at one of the Metro stations
around the city.
The train was extremely crowded, and she was
preparing to end the live video, planning
to resume once she reached her destination.
But just as she went to press the button and
end the stream, something strange happened.
The train went dark, and the space flooded
with a strange, thick liquid.
The girl screamed, in either pain, horror,
or both, and dropped the phone.
Whatever it fell into must have degraded the
phone at an extremely rapid pace, because
the video feed cut out immediately after a
SPLASH!
All across social media, people shared the
video with one question in mind: What happened
on that train?
Fans mounted a campaign to find the influencer,
to help her if she was in any immediate danger,
but there were no leads.
Her friends and family said she never came
home that day, and when authorities attempted
to trace her phone, they could not get any
kind of signal.
Becoming increasingly concerned about this
missing girl, and the possibility of some
kind of unreported train accident, authorities
contacted the Los Angeles Metro and showed
them the video footage.
But every train was accounted for and in pristine
condition.
There had been no strange chemical leaks,
no crashes, and certainly nothing like what
the video appeared to show.
At the same time, there were missing persons
reports being filed all across the country,
in every area with a thriving public transportation
system.
Not only were the occupants of the Los Angeles
train unaccounted for, with no wreckage or
bodies to be found, but people were disappearing
in train stations in New York, Boston, Chicago,
Washington, D.C., and more.
A woman reported her husband missing after
he called her to check in during his daily
commute home from work.
The train had kept going for much longer than
it ordinarily did, drifting off of its usual
route.
He told her that something was wrong, that
he had a terrible feeling of foreboding, and
then the call cut off.
He never made it home for dinner.
A young woman was on her way to start an internship
at a prestigious New York City magazine, but
never arrived for her first meeting.
When her would-be boss reached out to the
girl's roommate, all he knew was that she
had planned to take the train to work that
morning.
A private detective trailing a man's wife
for him, looking for evidence of an affair,
lost track of her when she stepped onto a
train downtown.
He took the next train, hoping to catch her
at what he assumed would be her stop, but
she never got off.
He wasn't able to track her down, and had
to give her suspicious husband the news that
his wife had somehow vanished into thin air.
It wasn't just one or two people every so
often, either.
Entire train cars of people were just disappearing,
never to be seen again.
No matter how hard anyone tried, they could
not find any answers, no logical explanation
for what could have happened.
Fortunately, the video circulated so widely
that it made it onto the feed of an SCP Foundation
employee, who was idly scrolling during a
bathroom break.
He was so shocked by what he saw that he almost
forgot to pull up his pants before running
out into the hall.
Fortunately, he did remember, and rushed to
his supervisor's office fully clothed.
After determining that the video was not a
hoax or some kind of viral marketing stunt
intended to sell a new brand of spicy chips,
the SCP Foundation decided to launch a formal
investigation into anomalous activity involving
trains and subway systems around the country.
Task forces were set up in every major city,
and field researchers were assigned to take
the train all day, every day, as much as possible.
As they did, they would maintain communication
with the head of their task force, who would
monitor their findings via hidden cameras
and microphones.
A week passed without incident, and the Foundation
was starting to wonder if, somehow, the Los
Angeles video had been faked, when the Chicago
task force made a harrowing discovery.
Officer Jamie Bower was assigned to monitor
the trains on Chicago's Blue Line, taking
the train throughout the day and keeping an
eye out for suspicious or potentially anomalous
activity.
One week in, and he pretty much had it down
to a basic routine.
He would grab breakfast, hop on the train,
and enjoy his coffee and meal while reading
a book and riding the train to its last stop.
Then, he'd pick up lunch and do the same thing
all over again.
He'd have dinner, and repeat.
It wasn't too exciting, but then again, excitement,
in this case, probably meant horrors beyond
his comprehension.
So, he was perfectly fine with traversing
the city in a subway car and catching up on
the backlog of murder mysteries he'd been
meaning to read.
It was Monday afternoon, he'd picked up a
slice of deep dish pizza, excited to try it
for the first time, and walked down into the
metro station as he took his first bite.
"Can you try not to chew into your microphone,
please?
It's gross," Dr. Susan Shepherd, the head
of the Chicago task force, spoke into Jamie's
earpiece.
"You got it, boss," he said, his mouth full.
"Thanks.
See anything unusual today?"
she asked.
"You tell me!
You can see the video feed, right?"
He took another bite, chewing as quietly as
he could.
"Sure, but you're there on the ground.
Just...keep an eye out, okay?
Be careful, and remember to draw your weapon
if something goes south.
Don't just disappear into your book and forget
to keep your wits about you," Dr. Shepherd
sighed.
"Yep!
Getting on the train now, not going to talk
much so these folks don't think I'm nuts."
Jamie waited for the doors to open, and for
just a moment, noticed that they seemed to
stick just a little this time.
Nothing to be too worried about, though.
Everything looked normal, just as it had on
every other ride he'd taken.
He could feel the Agatha Christie book calling
to him from inside of his tote bag, and he
wanted to crack it open and see what clues
Hercule Poirot had come across, but Dr. Shepherd
was right.
He'd been slacking off.
He needed to pay attention to his surroundings.
So, he did just that.
He watched as the train car steadily filled
up with strangers.
College students with bags full of books and
exhausted expressions, middle-aged people
in business attire, tourists wearing souvenir
baseball caps, and snapping pictures of everything
in sight.
Before too long, the train was completely
packed, and Jamie could barely move without
bumping elbows with someone.
It was a little claustrophobic, but that was
public transportation.
Jamie leaned back in his seat, pulled his
book out, and focused on the comforting rumble
of the engine, the rhythm of the wheels on
the tracks.
Suddenly, without warning, the train screeched
to a stop.
They were in the middle of a tunnel, Jamie
assumed, from the darkness that flanked them
out the window on either side.
Wait, was it dark?
Or had the windows just...disappeared?
He squinted through the blackness and tried
to see what was outside, but he couldn't make
sense of his surroundings.
All around, the other passengers were becoming
restless, nervous.
Some were calling for help; others were just
complaining.
"Doctor?
You seeing this?"
Jamie hissed into his microphone.
"I don't see a thing."
Dr. Shepherd replied.
"Are you alright?"
"Fine, the train's just stalled.
I don't know where.
Or what's wrong with it."
Jamie began feeling along the walls of the
train, looking for the doors.
"Huh.
That's weird..."
"What?"
"Well, the crack in the doors, where they
come together, should be right here...But
it's all smooth.
No gaps or anything, like it's all one thing.
And it feels strange...like-" He cut himself
off as his stomach dropped, a sudden rush
of fear flooding his senses.
"Like what?"
Dr. Shepherd pressed.
"Like it's alive," Jamie said, shakily.
"Campbell.
What's happening in there?"
Dr. Shepherd began taking furious notes on
her end.
"I don't know.
It's so dark.
Everyone's scared.
I'm scared.
I don't think this is a train, I don't know
what it is but it's nothing good..."
As Jamie felt around, he smelled something
sour, foul, and sharp in his nose.
He heard liquid splashing onto the ground,
the sound of something sizzling.
And then people started to scream.
As he felt along the wall, something dripped
onto his hand, and then it started to burn.
He cried out in agony as whatever had dripped
onto him ate away at the skin, dissolving
his hand bit by bit.
"What is it?"
Dr. Shepherd's voice shook as she heard the
pain in Jamie's voice.
"Some kind of acid, it's everywhere- It's
on the walls, the floor, it just keeps coming..."
He trailed off.
"Oh god, oh god.
We're in a stomach.
Whatever this is...it's eating us."
"Campbell, you need to get out of there.
Right now!"
Dr. Shepherd ordered.
"Draw your weapon.
Whatever you need to do, just get out!"
Jamie pulled out his weapon and started firing
at the place where the doors should be, but
the bullets bounced off uselessly as if the
fleshy material was the side of a tank.
He fired until there was no more ammunition
left, and then he kept squeezing the trigger
some more out of pure survival instinct.
But all it got him was a useless click, and
the certainty that the one thing he had brought
with him in case of emergency was completely
useless.
All the while, the acid was creeping higher,
dripping from every surface, filling the train
car until it swallowed the cries for help
and screams of fear and agony.
All Dr. Shepherd could do was listen, helpless,
as Jamie and the rest of the passengers were
digested inside of the massive stomach.
What happened to Officer Jamie Campbell was
tragic, but it provided important information
that the Foundation would likely never have
gotten otherwise.
They now knew a few key things about this
new anomaly: it was some kind of living thing
able to disguise itself as a train, it was
resilient to bullets and firearms, and it
was hiding in plain sight in order to hunt
human beings.
They had found the culprit for the rash of
mysterious disappearances, and it was a race
of unidentified creatures capable of taking
on the shape of a common underground train.
The newfound information quickly circulated
throughout the Foundation, making its way
to the various task forces assigned to Operation
Metro, as it had been unofficially nicknamed.
Task Force members were no longer instructed
to board trains.
Instead, they would slip hidden cameras onto
as many train cars as they possibly could,
each outfitted with a tracking device.
Then, the Foundation could remotely monitor
the trains for any potential signs of the
mysterious creatures, looking for imposters
masquerading as trains, without unnecessarily
losing any more operatives in action.
Now, as for what they would do once they found
one of these massive creatures was still uncertain,
but at least they had somewhere to start.
The SCP Foundation tried and failed to contain
several instances of the carnivorous species
before they finally got it right.
They attempted to freeze the inside of one
train with liquid nitrogen, hoping to incapacitate
the creature before it could feed, defend
itself, or escape custody.
The extreme cold seemed to have no effect,
however, and the false train slammed its doors
shut at the first sign of discomfort, then
sped away at a high speed.
As it did, the Task Force members noticed
that, though they could hear the sound of
wheels on the tracks, they could see legs
jutting out of the bottom of the creature,
scuttling along the ground.
Next, they attempted to take out the creature's
legs and render it immobile so that it could
be subdued.
The legs were resilient to external damage,
becoming hard as rock whenever any weapon,
blade, or other implement made contact with
them.
One task force member tried to physically
hold some of the legs in place, but they shifted
their shape, becoming appendages resembling
tentacles, and threw the man out of the way
before the false train hurried out of the
tunnel and out of sight.
They were able to track down a predatory train
just after a feeding, when it was slightly
sluggish after a large meal.
They pumped an aerosolized poison into the
train's interior, the belly of the beast,
potent enough to take out a dinosaur, and
were relieved to find that the creature was
unable to flee.
Unfortunately, though they were able to subdue
the creature, they killed it in the process.
At first, they assumed it was just inactive,
but it never resumed activity again.
It was just like an ordinary train car...almost.
When the interior was touched, it felt warm
and slightly pliable, less like metal and
plastic and more like flesh.
The longer the creature was still, the more
the windows on the sides stopped looking like
windows and started looking like wide, glassy
eyes.
The front of the train became a gaping maw,
the silhouette of the conductor inside revealed
as an extension of the creature's body, resembling
a tongue.
Survivors and witnesses were given an amnestic
to remove any memories of the supposed "killer
trains" running under their city, and the
Foundation prepared to bring the dead specimen
in for further study.
A cover story was used involving massive repairs
to the train system, and, while the tunnels
were closed off, they managed to remove the
creature and transport it to a nearby Foundation
Containment Site.
There, it was given one of the most extensive
autopsies in Foundation history, and the first
one conducted largely from inside of the subject.
The autopsy provided a more in-depth look
at the nature of the bizarre creature, and
its curious nature.
The creature, nicknamed the "train eater,"
referring to its preferred disguise and favorite
activity, was one of an apparent species of
carnivorous predators that used shapeshifting
and an advanced form of aggressive mimicry
to prey on commuters, tourists, and anyone
else in need of a ride from one place to the
next.
It would mimic the shape, feel, and sounds
of a train, welcoming unassuming victims into
its stomach, and, once it was completely full
and able to efficiently feed, it would release
an incredibly potent stomach acid into the
compartment and quickly dissolve everything
inside.
The creature was highly adaptable, able to
harden parts of its body at will and display
extreme resilience to weapons of any kind.
Due to this nearly impenetrable flesh, victims
trapped inside would be unable to force their
way out.
As the research staff turned in their autopsy
results and official report, there was a sense
of unease in the air as everyone wondered:
how many of these things are out there?
Which innocent trip to work might be their
last?
And how on earth could they hope to contain
something that could exist in endless numbers,
something so expert at hiding in plain sight?
There was no realistic way to bring all of
these creatures into custody, and so they
would have to neutralize as many as possible
without being detected.
Foundation operatives embedded in various
city and state governments introduced new
measures to renovate public transportation
systems, including new sanitation protocols.
As part of these protocols, all trains would
be sprayed with a high-strength "disinfectant"
before they could be certified for use.
In reality, this disinfectant would be the
same poison used to take down the first Train
Eater the Foundation studied.
Once any and all potential threats had been
rendered harmless, trains that were found
to be formerly living would be converted into
fully functioning trains, and allowed to run
as normal in order to avoid unnecessary interruptions
to the public.
In addition to these containment measures,
the Foundation monitors all social media for
mentions of unusual activity on trains, or
mentions of any more missing persons lost
at metro stations.
The original Los Angeles video that started
it all was scrubbed from the internet entirely.
So by all means, take advantage of your local
public transportation options, but remain
vigilant and keep your wits about you.
And remember next time you travel by train,
if you see something?
Say something.
More specifically, if you see something unusual
on a train, if it looks a little different
than it did yesterday, if its sounds don't
seem quite right, make sure to let everyone
around you know that it is not safe to be
here, and quickly make your way to the exit.
Then, maybe walk to your destination instead.
It might make you a little bit late, but hey,
better late than dinner.
Now go check out “SCP-342 - A Ticket to
Ride” and “SCP-2086 Man Eating Bus”
for more perilous anomalies on public transport!